the year was 2047
and this is all that was left the great
space wars between the Mustafar Ian's
and the Beza sites had depleted earth of
all its natural resources the Bitcoin
virus Andrew burrs robot chauffeurs and
finished the job
the only signs of humans had ever been
here were the ramshackle buildings and
the windmills the kept spinning and
spinning with nothing to power
everyone had abandoned her
everyone except for this man he was
known as decimal nah
detours
there's a modicum of truth in all of
this if you want to know what the world
will look like when it's a rundown mess
you can head to the mojave desert it's
here that you'll find some of the
world's greatest or at least most
eccentric inventors this craft is that
sexy beast pushing machines to their
limits
it's a place that Frost's with
engineering passion and that offers
total freedom to relentless tinkerers
join me on a road trip across the Mojave
from Los Angeles all the way to Las
Vegas as we meet people trying to change
the future of cars they are self-driving
and to make space cheap and easy we're
working on point-to-point travel one day
all in this episode of hello world
Silicon Valley may be home to some of
the biggest tech giants in the world but
it's being challenged like never before
crazy tech geniuses have popped up all
over the planet making things that will
blow your mind my name is Ashley Vance
I'm an author and journalist and I'm on
a quest to find the most innovative tech
creations and meet the beautiful freaks
behind them hello world this is the Los
Angeles that everyone knows
it's people hanging out on Venice Beach
killing some time watching skateboarders
getting a henna tattoo sweet and eating
a low-carb lunch as the Sun warms your
body and visions of Kardashian's bounce
around in your head but there's a part
of LA that I've always liked more for
decades la has been home to two thriving
communities of builders the people who
design cars and the people who build
spaceships many of them work in Polish
studios and massive industrial buildings
but the man I'm looking for works in a
place like this desert how are you good
to see you Ray I see it sir this is
desert Molnar and this is where it keeps
his toys so when we're driving slow we
keep the landing gear down and then once
we hit the freeway and we're in second
gear I'll bring the wheels up so don't
freak out
does your used to fly planes in the Air
Force
Betty built rockets and rocket powered
cars he's been in some bands
he's been rich he's been poor he's a
free spirit who does whatever he wants
like a lot of Angelenos deser often
finds himself stuck for hours on the
freeway wishing there was a way to rise
up and escape from the concrete prison
this is my first attempt at a flying car
in probably 2003
I felt pretty trapped in LA one day so I
started thinking about what the flying
car could do for me and the hierarchy of
nerd needs the flying car remains a must
have desert though doesn't see himself
as an inventor for the people he's out
for himself and the other select few
willing to live life on the edge
you don't think people think you're
crazy so here comes the flying car guy
again
the flying car as development has often
been mired in the idea that you have to
make something for everybody and that
you have to dumb it down so that it's a
consumer product to cut a few seconds
off of somebody's commute
I don't have the objective about
creating ubiquity da Vinci did one copy
of the Mona Lisa and it wasn't for
everybody and it wasn't like you had to
make 500 of them but it still has value
and I see a lot of the machines that
have been made as art pieces and I think
what they need is a gallery right now
they help drive the interest in the
development to drum up that interest
desert soon plans to start a flying car
racing Lea in the Mojave Desert there's
a long-standing marriage between LA and
the Mojave it's in LA where engineers go
about their day jobs and fancy offices
and it's in the Mojave where the folks
who can never stop experimenting go to
try out their ideas on the weekends
Mojave is sort of what it's like the
playground for the testbed it's about
the people you want to meet as opposed
to people that you don't need its those
are the freaks you know that that matter
to me are the ones that want to go out
there and take their 300 mile an hour
jet car out on a Saturday afternoon yeah
I'll see you with the free okay you can
join the club
Mojave is about a two-hour drive into
the California desert from Los Angeles
and most of that time is spent staring
at bumpers God is driving socked deal
with this and yes the flying car seems
like a great idea but as we made our way
out into the inventer Badlands the
reality of zipping across the desert in
a loose assembly of metal pipes and good
intentions felt somewhere between stupid
and terrifying the truth though is that
much of this technology is
tried-and-true the first part of desert
flying car plan hinges on this
gyrocopter
these types of vehicles have been flying
since the 1920s they're cheap relatively
easy to build and pretty reliable
instead of running on a motor the
propeller gets its lift from the wind as
the craft goes forward
incredible that it's crazy you should
get like this totally different
perspective
if the engine cuts out the copter which
is fluttered down to the ground like a
leaf falling out of a tree my adrenaline
was pumping right before we took off but
you know like the second we were in the
air I mean you just there's a lot to see
it's pretty here I sort of forget about
at all yeah and as you saw I mean
obviously there's we can land anywhere
out here so it's a perfect place the
gyrocopter takes care of the up part of
the flying car puzzle but you still need
something to deal with the rows for that
deser has this slick concept vehicle the
goal is to marry the two and have
something that turns just about any road
into a runway when that happens okay if
that happens the select few willing to
give it a go will taste freedom while
the rest of us rot on the 405 I think
that the reality is a lot of people in
this world like to have some kind of an
advantage in life no matter what they're
doing whether it's a bigger stereo or a
you know a swimming pool at their house
but the reality is that in nature all
birds can walk all bugs that fly have
legs and they can fold their wings up on
their back they survive in different
environments because they've adapted to
get through them to say that we're going
to spend 40 billion hours a year in the
United States sitting in traffic saying
that well no one will ever have one of
these I don't really care if that's the
party line
you can make something that will allow
you to escape this ridiculous aunt line
of eternity
up next I head to a spiritual oasis in
the desert you get a chance to find out
who you really are what you really like
and check out the home of the new space
movement with Richard Branson you
important thing is to make sure it's
safe and feel for return tickets not
single tickets for any successful spirit
quest engineering-based or otherwise
you're gonna want to get yourself a
shaman
I found a spirit guide who calls himself
Ricky Ricardo
the proud and wonderfully eccentric
owner of this desert compound
it's a spot that's cut off from
civilization but right in the middle of
a transdimensional energy vortex or
something like that
this was actually many many years ago
this was an actual Indian crossing all
around here is just like a treasure
trove of arrowheads and artifact it's
amazing
Ricci has a house in LA but he spends
most of his time here hanging out with
the other Desert Rats and feeling free
back in 93 My partner and I went to
Burning Man amazing changed my life I
said well geez why can't I expend that
two weeks into a whole year I decided to
live my life like that
Ricci worked for years on Hollywood
productions and he likes to invite
friends and complete strangers out for
massive desert rains the art
installations from past parties dot his
land mostly though he's out here riding
his great American screenplay alone and
off the grid does this phone work uh
yeah if you're talking to yourself maybe
that's what it takes to make it out here
in LA
some introspection that's what takes up
more of your time than anything I think
when you're out here is your that
conversation with God kind of thing you
know
it goes back to the saying if you really
like yourself you really don't have a
problem because you you get a chance to
really explore the depths of your own
person you know to find out who you
really are and what you really like
not everyone comes to the desert to find
God some come for the simple pleasure of
blowing stuff up and just down the road
from Ricky these people have created
their own temple to destruction this is
the stomping ground of far where the
Friends of amateur rocketry all sorts of
people come here to blow stuff up from
hobbyists right up onto the big boys
like SpaceX about 15 years ago a group
of amateur rocketry enthusiasts decided
to buy their own plot of land today
hordes of university students have
turned up to fire off their year-end
projects where's that flag
I got you keep that pressure on the kids
are all members of SEDs we're the
students for the exploration and
development of space this group of about
a hundred kids hopes to make history if
we're successful here today will be the
first students in the world to to launch
a rocket powered by a 3d printed engine
the students design the engine
themselves and it's comparable to
technology big aerospace companies have
only recently started to explore and
today marks the culmination of months of
work I went to bed between
three or four in the morning we're up at
six in the morning so I'm kind of run
off a couple hours of sleep Darrin
sherrier is the incoming president of
UCSD team he sees 3d printing is the
future of rocketry traditionally these
things had to be manufactured by hand as
students now have the ability to kind of
design it on a computer send it over to
manufacturer and it just gets printed
off did we get any movement all right
let's check it again Brian dear King
leads the recovery team for UCSD we know
the engine works it's more of a question
of will everything work this time
throughout the day one rocket went off
after another as other university teams
tested their gear as the hours tick by
specter of unease hung over the San
Diego team they were way behind schedule
and the wind kept picking up
most of the far old-timers figured the
San Diego rocket would fail these
engineering students have worked their
ass off and they're all excited and you
know part of coming out here it's kind
of sad to watch people get their dreams
stomped I'll say this about the San
Diego team they listen to the naysayers
all day long and stuck to their guns
after hours and hours of delays the
tired squirrely kids buckled down to see
if they could prove the rocket veterans
real a0y in the end the Rockets soared
into the sky and flew perfectly youth
prevailed
well the team's parachute failed to open
which meant the rocket came crashing to
the ground the parachute had been
Bryan's responsibility and it took the
crash hard I clearly didn't help his
mood oh there it is clapping best the
rest of the team took the experience and
strike they traveled out to the wreckage
with glee and went hunting for souvenirs
her parachutes deployed but that's all
right gone off that was the main goal of
this mission and what are you gonna do
to celebrate we're gonna go back maybe
and we're just gonna sleep out here in
the Mojave there's testing rockets and
then there's testing runs
be a kick-ass rocket company you know
you need to test a lot
the folks who succeed are able to
iterate quickly many of these young
rocket tears will head here after they
graduate
it's the Mojave Airport which is
situated smack dab in the center of
Mojave the town this is where the big
kids play with fire and the pyromaniacs
over at Virgin Galactic hope to soon
offer tourists a chance to visit space
for about two hundred fifty thousand
dollars per ticket we're about twice
that on StubHub George Whitesides is a
NASA veteran and serves as the CEO of
Virgin Galactic he gave me a tour of
their operations which includes a test
stand for braking in rocket engine
Nature does not like what we're trying
to do here the art of this is taking
something that nature doesn't want and
sort of bending it into an outcome
virgin spaceship will be carried into
the air underneath the plane the
spaceship will then fire up its own
thrusters and head for the heavens
it's a complex system and there are a
few places on earth where you can work
out the kinks it's the only place in the
United States where you can design
manufacture and test a rocket motor and
then integrate it on a spaceship and fly
it into space you know this is this is
really the frontier of American
aerospace Virgen wants to offer more
than just a joyride it thinks people
visiting space even for just a few
minutes will have a profound effect on
how we all see our planet you know so
we've got 700 people quarter magnitude
signed up to go on our spaceship that's
more than the number of people who have
ever been to space in 50 years but
they're gonna go back to communities all
over the world and they're gonna bring
that perspective with them I think
that's gonna have a really important
effect the story of virgin has been one
of great promise and devastating
setbacks in 2014 the company's first
spaceship crashed to the ground killing
the copilot and injuring the pilot today
this press event virgin hopes to restore
confidence in its technology by
unveiling spaceship to Richard Branson's
attempt to resurrect the Galactic Empire
from the ashes
this one has taken more than ten years
you're still not at the point where
we're flying yet how difficult has this
business been compared to your others it
is rocket science it is really difficult
we're just reinventing the wheel
completely reinventing the technology so
it's been tough but we now have a
rockets that we know will take us to
space you know we feel confident that
we're finally very very close to being
there ever a good and devoted son
Branson decorated the spaceship with his
mother's likeness and ever the good
showman used the spaceships unveiling as
an excuse to throw a birthday party for
his granddaughter that's a bottle of
milk made out of sugar and I used to the
customer in 2014 after the accident how
close were you to tell me I don't think
I've ever given up on anything in life
but we would have been irresponsible not
to ask the questions
the important thing is not to hurry a
program like this you've important thing
is to get it right and make sure it's
safe for people to go up and and that we
offer return tickets not single tickets
up next I take a road trip into the
future this stuff seemed like science
fiction but it's actually science back
and head down the Las Vegas Strip in a
self-driving car
it's the sort of invitation you wait a
lifetime to receive
come to the Mojave
we're camping out next to the trona
pinnacles
they're weird and beautiful incest there
will be beers and burgers and tequila
and a bunch of gearheads and techno
freaks hanging out together
we're going to show you how we're
reinventing cars he says and we're gonna
go spine crushing fast
this is Mouse McCoy is a sort of hotrod
Renaissance man with a vision on where
the cars of tomorrow are designed by
artificial intelligence right now we're
in the space where like this stuff
seemed like science fiction but it's
actually science fact like we're living
science fact right before our eyes and
to be a part of it
this feels feels good mouse mouse grew
up in Los Angeles is the son of a pair
of producers he moved up the Hollywood
ladder going from stunt man to action
director but it was his time racing
bikes out here as a kid that he said
inspired him to come up with a better
way to build vehicles growing up out
here and racing motorcycles out here you
really understood cost of failure like
it was a gnarly place like you're
crashing motorcycles as a kid that I
feel like I sort of forged out here in a
way his latest venture is called hacker
ID the goal is to blend human emotion
and technology to spur an automotive
revolution to do this Mouse and his team
measure everything they can they wire up
cars with dozens of sensors to see how
the metal performs then they create 3d
maps of their racing courses to figure
out exactly how the car behaves and on
top of all that they strap brainwave
monitors on their heads to detect stress
I think it's safe to say that as I strap
in for today's test I'm showing signs of
anxiety already hopefully we'll see pure
panic in the brain monitor
the hot rod team doesn't start with an
off-the-shelf car chassis
they use artificial intelligence
software to come up with designs and
fabricate them on a 3d printer design
software and new manufacturing
techniques have gotten good enough to
allow a small group of people to build
custom cars from scratch we're getting
in this mass world where just design
decisions are dictated your aesthetic is
dictated by some corporate strategy
somewhere and it's like that was that
hot rodder you know sort of thing and a
lot of our mission here is going to be
about individualization like having your
own design having your own vehicle this
is a full car
Felix holes used to oversee the Hot
Wheels and matchbox brands from Mattel
he's a car junkie who quit the Mattel
game to start hacker out with Mouse we
think this may be the first shutter
that's been engineered with artificial
intelligence that AI sucks up data
collected from the desert field tests
Felix gives it a few guidelines and it
spits out a body design you test it feed
the data back in and get an even better
car out what used to take years and
hundreds of Engineers can now be done in
a matter of months with state-of-the-art
tools and full of people or so hacker ID
hopes to prove we both come from a kind
of hotrod culture that hacker culture
and we looked at this as like look we're
not Ford or Ferrari or whoever we don't
have hundreds and hundreds of Engineers
to start designing a chassis from the
ground up there's a real democratization
of creativity and design going on that
we that we don't we stand for
this car is called the mule it was the
first built using hot rod technology and
it's been utterly abused by mouse over
the course of three days soon and we
time to head back to LA and let the
computers do their work to replace it
with mule 2.0
what's your vision for where this
company is in like five years in five
years I think we will have been a
significant driver in the automatic
manufacturing world that's coming
after spending a couple of days at rota
getting covered in grease and dust
so much dust I plotted my escape from
the Mojave my final stop would be Las
Vegas given the nature of this trip
I couldn't just hop in any old Honda I
needed something special
something that would leave a mark on Sin
City so I hit up an old friend who
happens to have his own homemade
self-driving car
problem solved they're a couple miles
out of Barstow an acid kicked him where
hunter s Thompson had dr. gonzo as a
companion I have this guy George Hotz he
comes with less drugs the plenty of fear
and loathing hots became famous as a
teenager for hacking everything in sight
he hacked the iPhone he hacked the Sony
Playstation he has the legal fees to
prove it and now he's hacking cars he
stunned the world last year by building
this self-driving car by himself in a
San Francisco garage in just a couple of
months I visited him back then to see
his Acura packed full of cameras radars
and artificial intelligence software
unlike the Tesla's and Google's of the
world Potts doesn't give his car a
litany of rules to follow he basically
just drives the thing and the car learns
to mimic the behavior and does so better
and better over time don't get off the
exit I'll do it I know you want to I
know you want to I know you see that
exit oh good job car Hots hasn't bested
Knight Rider yet but he has achieved
Hasselhoff s heights of confidence
meanwhile back on the road to Vegas soon
we'll probably be able to drive without
radar just using the camera just using a
camera and cameras like our cell phone
that camera is good enough to drive the
car
I can keep bashing everyone like I'm the
underdog but am I really the underdog I
have a working self-driving car not
everyone appreciates Hutt's unique brand
of gusto the California DMV for example
recently told Hots to quit driving his
experiment on the state's roads this is
why we've had to head to the Nevada
border where the true freedom of the
Mojave lives on we're getting close to
the border the border I'll press the
button once we hit the border why can't
we do it in California they don't like
innovation Nevada loves innovation
that's what I heard oh I see the sign I
see you son
prepare to engage on your command
captain all right here we go
welcome to Nevada 3 the silver stick to
one be yourself drive Hudson's car had
never seen the Nevada roads before but
it drove perfectly on its own for miles
that is until the Desert Sun dipped down
casting shadows across the road there's
actually the worst time of day for it
the contrast is not very good as the Sun
is so bright still and the road is so
dim and look you see now no no you can't
drive Wow look I can't see anything in
the picture
this is really bad what does house make
you think is this something you can fix
over time a lot of this has to do with
camera a lot of the bug right now is
just cuz the camera can't say that led
to a minor existential crisis by the
time we got to Vegas
at which point hots feverishly began
trying to debug his autonomous roadster
we'd come all this way to tries cars
newest feature the ability to go
hands-free and stop and go traffic
but as we inch our way towards the strip
to see if his fixes would work it seemed
like the stress of being a boy genius
might be getting to him I've been
frustrated lately by just a lot of
rigmarole and [ __ ] that comes with
this it's not fun anymore
this was fun when it was me building a
car but once money got involved and
expectations got invited just it just
became stupid as we rounded the corner
and the glittering lights came into view
I tried to cheer him up
well let's just see what happens you
might go too soon it might go too soon
oh no it sees them there it sees them
there ya go
don't hit the man don't hit the bed
very nice yeah good car Oh God strippers
- like strippers
let's closer than a show god that's his
car passed the test and his existential
eggs lifting the legend of dr. Haas
lives are feeling better now yeah let's
got us good full autonomy haven't
disengaged
it's easy to be cynical these days in
knock America it's the place with the
tubby people we forgot how to make
things and who don't like to get their
hands dirty anymore
but then you come somewhere like Mojave
and receive a stark reminder that some
of America's most endearing elements
remain alive and well it's in the middle
of all this nothingness that passion
pure passion has a chance to thrive if
the cynics want to remain cynical that's
fine if they don't they should put on
some sunscreen buy a pair of goggles and
take a trip out to the desert to see
what happens when creative adults get a
giant playground up next on hello world
I'll trade in the desert for the beaches
and rain forests of Australia I'll go
for a swim with the robot had a dinosaur
and get my spelunker